-Performing
"Then It All Goes Away"
from his album,
"People in Motion",
please welcome Dayglow!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ Come on now ♪
♪ It's not always the same ♪
♪ You can't tell me
you don't notice ♪
♪ Probably the same things ♪
♪ 'Cause I know the things
that you've been talking about ♪
♪ And sometimes I can't ever
believe what you say, yeah ♪
♪ It's only in the way
I'm feeling this down ♪
♪ That nothing seems to change ♪
-♪ One, two, yeah ♪
♪ You tell me everything ♪
♪ You tell me it's fine, but ♪
♪ There's something tells me ♪
♪ That there's something
going on here ♪
♪ I know the way you got
that look in your eyes ♪
♪ And then it disappears ♪
♪ So then ♪
♪ You're telling me there's
something different about it ♪
♪ Even though we've been
circling around it ♪
♪ Since forever, and forever ♪
♪ It goes like ♪
♪ 'Cause I know the things
that you've been talking about ♪
♪ And sometimes I can't ever
believe what you say, yeah ♪
♪ It's only in the way
I'm feeling this down ♪
♪ That nothing seems to change ♪
-♪ One, two, yeah ♪
♪ You tell me everything ♪
♪ You tell me it's fine, but ♪
♪ There's something tells me ♪
♪ That there's something
going on here ♪
♪ I know the way you got
that look in your eyes ♪
♪ And then it disappears ♪
-♪ And then it all goes away ♪
♪ Then it all goes away ♪
-♪ Oh, yeah ♪
♪♪
-♪ And then it all goes away ♪
-♪ 'Cause I know the things
that you've been talking about ♪
♪ And sometimes I can't ever
believe what you say, yeah ♪
♪ It's only in the way
I'm feeling this down ♪
♪ That nothing seems to change ♪
-♪ One, two, yeah ♪
-♪ You tell me everything ♪
♪ You tell me it's fine, but ♪
♪ There's something tells me ♪
♪ That there's something
going on here ♪
♪ I know the way you got
that look in your eyes ♪
♪ And then it disappears ♪
-♪ And then it all goes away ♪
♪ It all goes away ♪
♪ Then it all goes away ♪
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]